talking of kids you've you've got the
three wars who did all play football
yeah but now they've basically all
dumped it and yeah so it's Harper the
only one left she is the only one left
and she started playing every Sunday and
I mean she loves it the boys don't play
anymore which is a it's heartbreaking
they were playing a bit Adarsh a good
plan and they're great I mean they're
amazing yeah I mean they're goofing
around with the yeah yeah good they're
bad the talent but obviously none of
them play anymore so it's down to Harper
so she's yeah I took it to a training
session the other day and she's she's
running around and I'm quite as I
wouldn't say aggressive dead on the side
of the field because probably the wrong
thing to say but I'm very I just get I'm
very enthusiastic mixed team it's a
mixed team okay and so half was doing
really well she's kind of dribbling with
the ball and then this boy runs into her
and I was and I was like what had I was
looking around at the other parents
thinking how do I react do I be a UNICEF
ambassador
okay define or do I be Harper's daddy
and be like really so I just let it go
[Music]
you